Speaker 1: David, should free speech apply to
social media? The First Amendment only protects
against government censorship, but should it
protect free speech in the way that social media
is speech as well? Listen, there's basically no
I mean, the First Amendment means what the First
Amendment means. It comes to encompass government
limiting speech. If you want a First Amendment
to also cover what you write on Twitter so Twitter
can't ban you, you either have to change what is
in the First Amendment to have it include
private companies, which would be extremely
anti libertarian, quite frankly. I mean,
if that's a big regulation of business
or you have to make social media part of
government, you have to nationalize social media.
I don't see that happening. That seems
like a complete and total nonstarter. Now,
there's a couple of other things that I think
are important to think about if you do. Include
social media companies as governed by the First
Amendment and by the government more broadly,
you are restricting the First Amendment
and free speech rights of those companies.
What do I mean by that? Well, think
about it. If you are Twitter and you
can have terms of service, you can enforce the
terms of service as you see fit as long as you're
not violating any law. Twitter wouldn't be able
to say, well, we don't allow anyone we believe to
be black to tweet. That would violate specific
nondiscrimination law. But if you just blanket
say now, you've got to let people say whatever
they want, you can enforce your terms of service.
That is a limitation on Twitter's First Amendment
rights. That is a limitation on Twitter's ability
to govern itself as a private business, which
Republicans claim to want. So not only does
it not make sense to apply First Amendment
protections when it comes to social media,
not only would you have to change the First
Amendment or nationalize social media, you're also
restricting the speech of those companies. Part
of free speech is a company and you can define.
How your platform works, what what happens on
your property, in your business, on your platform,
as long as it doesn't violate any law, forcing
people to tolerate speech that Twitter doesn't
want on their platform is a restriction on
Twitter. You are coming down on Twitter. You
are you're regulating Twitter in a way that
is not actually justified by the law. So
a couple of different things. First of all. If
the government wanted to regulate online speech.
Would they have a responsibility to provide some
kind of alternative platform of sorts? If so,
isn't that very problematic? Second, might we
not benefit from some kind of publicly governed
infrastructure for helping people to assess the
accuracy of the things that they read online? And
this really goes back to education. A lot of this
stuff that we're dealing with about shouldn't and
anti vax is just ideas. It's speech. It should
be allowed. Well, no, it's actually dangerous
to public health. It shouldn't be allowed.
Putting aside the legality of whether Twitter
can say no anti back stuff, whether YouTube
can say no anti back stuff, putting aside the
legality because it is legal, wouldn't we all be
better off? With a much more educated population
such that they never start even falling for the
anti back stuff and way fewer people even think
to spread the anti VAX stuff, and that is an area
where I think the government could play a role
furthering media literacy. I'm open to the idea
of a nonpartizan commission on media literacy. The
question, of course, is, is it always going to be
just influenced by whoever's in the White House at
the time? It should be protected from that. And
I don't know if that means it's governed by an
equal number of Republicans and Democrats, then
you just kind of have a partizan fight over it,
or could there be some other way? I think
it could be done. And I think that that that
would be a great thing to do. And then lastly,
by the way. A lot of the real cases to be made
against some of these companies are really
monopoly cases. We have antitrust law on the
books that there has been very little appetite in
enforcing for a very, very long time. Republicans
now want it enforced, but only as it impacts
social media. They don't care about it in oil.
They don't care about it in energy and in other
areas. They want it enforced with social media.
Without commenting on that hypocrisy, if you
want to more stringently regulate social media,
we have an apparatus to do it. And it's called
antitrust law. We've done interviews with experts
on it in the past. There seems to be
very little appetite to actually do that.